o bom dia fez barulho foi da minha
respiração do microfone
a ansiedade é quando fui convidado para
participar desse evento aqui falando
sobre os sons da nossa vida eu fiquei
primeiro pensamento que me veio foi como
resume 44 anos de vida e de música uma
palestra de 12 a 15 máximo 18 minutos né
e aí me veio o primeiro pensamento de
que como a música mudou a minha vida
a música entra na minha vida desde muito
cedo e ela transforma a minha vida
durante esses vários momentos dessa
trajetória desde muito novo a partir da
influência do meu pai eu começo a
perceber esse ambiente musical né
e aí a música vai me acompanhando
nessa transformação de filho para pai de
um adolescente rebelde para um
profissional responsável a e tantas
outras transformações que ocorrem nas
nossas vidas e que estão cercados na
maioria das vezes por muitos ambientes
musicais né pra falar da música da minha
vida já citei o meu pai até vou pedir
desculpas aqui pra minha mãe que depois
vai ver o vídeo e vai ver que eu não
falei nela se eu fosse falar sobre
educação sobre o mestrado e outras
coisas relacionadas a essa área com
certeza eu falaria da minha mãe mas como
eu vou falar da música na minha vida eu
preciso falar do meu pai porque a música
chega até mim através dele né porque o
meu pai gostava muito de cantar meu pai
era um ser humano totalmente musical
mesmo sem saber tocar uma nota
e eu me lembro da minha infância de
quando a casa era invadida pelas rodas
de chorinho com muitos violões bandolins
cavaquinhos e aquele ambiente
sensacional que que se transformava ao
meu redor é o meu pai costumava cantar
sempre carinhoso grande canção do
pixinguinha que quem quem talvez não
conheça é aquela do
o meu coração não sei porque bate feliz
quando tv e os meus olhos ficam sorrindo
bom não vim aqui pra cantar mas é essa
música que o pai cantava ea partir dali
eu comecei a perceber essas conexões de
como a música amo dava o ambiente mudava
o humor das pessoas e acaba criando
conexões emocionais são bacanas nem as
pessoas cantavam junto com ela se
emocionavam choravam e se abraçavam riam
em e enfim aquilo passou a ser para mim
algo mágico algo inspirador algo até
transcedental porque é o meu país já
morreu há muito tempo e tem muita coisa
que eu não consegui dizer pra ele ea
música faz com que ele esteja presente
na minha vida até hoje é então até tem
até uma conexão espiritual
nessa música na minha vida né hoje eu já
consigo ouvir as músicas do roberto e do
erasmo sem aquele choro da dor da perda
do meu pai e sim com aquele choro de
gratidão do reconhecimento de uma
história legal que ele me deixou
mas a música na minha vida é muito mais
que isso é a música me transformou de
adolescente perdido sem saber o que
fazer de estagiário em um grande banco
brasileiro a entrar no rádio porque eu
sempre ficava ouvindo música no rádio e
pensava em como seria legal tocar as
músicas que eu gosto para as pessoas
como seria bacana discotecar uma festa
ou como é essa possibilidade é
fantástica né
isto poderia mobilizar milhares de
pessoas com a música e as pessoas
sentirem sentimentos parecidos coisas
emoções parecidas né e ainda bem que eu
fui parar no rádio se não seria um
daqueles caras que bota aquelas caixas
de som no porta mala e vai pra beira da
praia vai incomodar todo mundo né então
é acabei indo parar no rádio por causa
da música porque eu realmente não sabia
o que fazer quando eu era um adolescente
e aí depois vive
é o meu pai e estava trabalhando no
banco algo que pra mim é muito distante
do que eu faço hoje do que eu faço há 25
anos
então através da música e também meus
filhos não me ouçam porque uma tem muita
aula para ouvir discos no centro no
centro de porto alegre naquela época
várias lojas de discos tinham os
toca-discos enfileirados era lindo
chegar nas lojas e pegar alguns discos
para ouvir e às vezes quando eu eu eu
não estava com muita vontade na aula eu
ia lá ouvir discos nas lojas do centro e
muitas vezes não tinha grana pra comprar
na maioria das vezes não tinha dinheiro
pra comprar talvez por isso hoje eu seja
um colecionador compulsivos vinil época
hoje já dá pra comprar o disco in
mas enfim ali nas lojas de discos e
também conheci um ambiente bacana de
troca de informações porque nos anos 80
e início dos 90 a gente não tinha tanta
informação como a gente tem hoje para
saber o que é aquele artista com
qualquer dele né a gente trocar
informações com quem sabe um pouco mais
do que nós que eram os vendedores de
discos e as pessoas que freqüentavam as
lojas então aprendi muito sobre música
lembra encartes lendo ficha técnica de
lps de encartes de cds e isso foi me
fazer parar no rádio na rádio ipanema em
1992 é e aí as descobertas nerds de
heavy metal nos anos 80 com o rock in
rio aquelas bandas que eu gostava black
sabbath iron maiden passando pelo rock
de bittles de stones the doors chegando
no rock brasileiro dos anos 80 que foi
uma transformação completa na minha vida
porque o grande artista também tem isso
é o grande artista consegue botar pra
fora o que muita gente está sentindo
aquelas coisas que eu sentia aqueles
artistas expressaram as suas canções aí
eu me sentir completamente representado
depois disso ainda vem a ampliação de
consciência que chega através da música
de bob marley
isso não tem nada a ver com uma campanha
pessoal tem tem a ver com a com a obra
do balé que eu vou falar
isso não devia mas eu vou falar que
ficou por trás dessa cortina de fumaça a
e na verdade é muito mais né uma música
dique que prega o amor à união apase
principalmente uma música de contestação
uma música de luta por direitos iguais
por justiça
uma música representativa do terceiro
mundo onde nós vivemos porque o baleia é
ainda o grande artista terceiro
mundistas sair do saído de uma ilha na
saída da jamaica ali no caribe
o bala e conquistou o mundo com essa
mensagem da sua música então am
todas essas conexões podem ser feitas
nas a a emoção que a música sempre
desperta e as novas portas que a música
abre no nosso universo durante a vida
porque a música tem esse poder de ser
uma chave que abre diversas portas que
mostra diversos caminhos novas maneiras
de perceber a vida e o mundo né
a música também tem muito a ver com a
liberação de dopamina no cérebro a
sensação de prazer que a gente sente ao
se alimentar a fazer sexo e outras
coisas a música nos proporciona e mas
voltando a falar um pouco mais sobre a a
a trajetória a minha trajetória pessoal
e desse sentimento em relação ao meu pai
e à música
muitas vezes a gente fica sem ouvir
determinados sons para não lembrar de
determinadas pessoas né eu fiquei muito
tempo sem ouvir algumas canções do
roberto e do erasmo e outras que eu
ouvia no carro com meu pai porque me
dava uma dor imensa lembrar dele a
sentir a falta dele
sentia aquela dor e muitas vezes quando
a gente terminar relacionamentos
amorosos
ficamos também um bom tempo sem ouvir
determinadas músicas sem tocar em alguns
discos ou pensar em alguns artistas
porque aquela música ou aquele artista
nos remete diretamente a pessoa amada
ainda no caso o nosso espaço seria ex
namorado e ex namorado
enfim
o legal de tudo isso é que o tempo vai
passando e aquelas músicas podem vir
novamente só é diferente nos causar
sensações completamente diferentes e
hoje eu sinto isso quando eu escuto
essas músicas de roberto e erasmo as
coisas pra ver com o meu pai
essa sensação de gratidão
na verdade eu tenho muito a agradecer a
música porque a música me fez a música
me faz a música me transforma
diariamente e ela proporciona que
através do meu trabalho no rádio eu
criei esses contextos emocionais com
outras pessoas com os meus ouvintes que
muitas vezes me mandou e mail me param
na rua e dizem que legal o que tocou
hoje de manhã aquele assunto no
despertador que é um pedacinho do meu
programa no rádio onde a gente liga pra
pessoas através de uma solicitação de
e-mail e e como é é gratificante poder
ser o elo de ligação entre as pessoas
através da música né isso é
completamente fantástico para mim poder
tá sendo essa essa ligação essa ponte
que cria conexões tão bacanas com as
pessoas então tem que agradecer a todos
os músicos que de certa forma passaram
pela minha vida os shows que eu assistir
aos hits aos punk is all blacks os
sambistas anarquistas todas as pessoas
que fazem música e deixam essa obra como
grande diamante da humanidade e
agradecer principalmente ao meu pai que
me deu a música me mostrou a música mas
não me mostrou só isso me mostrou uma
maneira de viver me mostrou uma forma de
encarar a vida que é muito legal e uma
uma forma de viver de encarar a vida que
eu posso passar para os meus filhos
então quando os meus filhos no carro
eles estão ali pedindo pra mim pai volta
aquela música repete repete o que houve
de novo eu fico lá repetindo exaustiva
às vezes porque eu sei que um dia quando
não estiver mais aqui
eles vão lembrar de mim através daquela
música e isso é pra sempre né
isso é pra sempre não há corpo físico
que acabe com essas emoções
muito obrigado